this is a fantastic question how do we  know human body temperature is dropping  couldn't it just be that the methods we  use to measure temperature are changing  well researchers have considered that  and what they found is that the effect  does not depend on method of thermometry  at all instead it only depends on birth  year if you were to look at all the  measurements made by one doctor using  one device on one day you can still see  the effect it's not that the  measurements we get are dropping over  time it's that newer born people are  coming out and running cooler than those  born before and we don't know why if you  want some more Mysteries check out the  website where I first learned about this  body temperature decline with Enigma  it's a Wiki not of things we know but of  things we don't and if you're watching  this video somewhere besides Instagram  or Tick Tock go follow me on Instagram  or Tick Tock because I can make longer  vertical videos there  I love you